because if we can't protect the Earth
you can be damn well sure we'll avenge
it'll wait he said sometimes there isn't
a way out
the first time you lost a soldier we are
not soldiers we lost all of us
Plus friends who lost family
you lost a part of ourselves hey
everybody it's Charlie big news there
was a whole bunch of Avengers endgame
Captain Marvel it just MCU stuff to drop
this morning you also probably heard
about the interview Kevin Feige did
talking about the x-men Fox Disney deal
closing much earlier and some of their
plans that are going on behind the
scenes right now so we'll break it all
down there's giveaway stuff at the end
of the video but I'm gonna play that
clip of Kevin Feige talking about Fox
Disney x-men deal in the overflow with
Disney Plus and all the extra MCU
projects there won't be movies but we'll
make it to that Disney Plus streaming
service he also talks a little bit about
Stan Lee as well too so we'll include
that whenever we announce a slate we
haven't done it now for four years or so
but we we did a big event at the El
Capitan Theatre I think it was four
years ago yeah where we announced I
can't remember exactly but 10 movies
maybe and I did a little a little Q&A
with with press afterwards v-very like
the first five questions were what about
this character what about this other
character what about this movie and I
thought whoa wait a minute we just
announced ten or whatever was new movies
isn't that enough and what's amazing is
no no it's not it's not enough which
goes to which goes to how many great
characters there are in these comics
yeah so so I think there are a lot of
them I can't remember what the official
word is of 8,000 characters or ten
thousand could they all be movies no of
course not but could a hundred I you
know maybe and so many different types
that's why you know the the earthbound
stories that we've done getting to a
cosmic space was always very important
to me I'm a big I'm a big fan of of
science fiction in outer space movies
which now which now we've done the
supernatural side metaphysical side of
things with the Dutch strange universe
and there's still others that we haven't
tapped into yet in terms of in terms of
genre plays which is what we always like
to do so there's lots there the notion
of the characters that had previously
been under a Fox agreement coming back
is great
number one it's nice when a company that
that that created all these characters
can have access to all those characters
it's unusual not to Marvel has been in a
unique position to not have access to
the characters a long time and for me
going full circle to our conversation
that's where I started mm-hmm that's
where I started you know almost 20 years
ago yeah
so that's so it's exciting but in terms
of actually thinking about it and
actually planning things we haven't
started that yet but we've been told
it's it is it's looking very good and
and and could happen in the in four six
months of next year he was very special
and he was I've always said you know
anybody who met Stan I've never heard
one story of somebody meeting Stan and
not being overwhelmed and I was lucky
enough to see him about ten days before
he passed away coincidentally went went
to his house to see him in some ways I
never thought this day would come I
thought he'd be going you know Kirk
Douglas just turned 102 I thought Stan
was gonna be there and literally outlive
all of us and in the same ways it
doesn't seem like he's gone because just
like Walt Disney on this lot his
influence will will never will never go
well he is immortal because these
characters were going anywhere sure so
yeah he's absolutely so he says a whole
lot during that that's like a fraction
of the actual full interview that he did
there was a big variety podcast that he
did recently where he talks about his
beginnings in the industry he mentions
geoff johns when he was working for the
donners as an intern before he became a
PA than talking about the early x-men
films when he was in the industry but
the important stuff that take away from
this is that recently MSNBC and a couple
of other news outlets were reporting
that the Fox Disney deal might be done
as early as the end of January I'm not
expecting it to be done that fast if
Kevin Feige says the first six months
that's probably a conservative estimate
so probably some time before that like
between Captain Marvel and Avengers
endgame whereas previously I wouldn't
have said too much later in the year but
the funny thing about that is just as
Kevin Feige is ramping up to make MCU
x-men films the Dark Phoenix people will
be hitting their press tour to promote
their film which is coming out during
the summer all while we're still
dissecting Avengers endgame in the end
of their ten-year journey so there's
gonna be so much big Marvel and x-men
stuff happening between March and
July is gonna be crazy sidenote take
away two because he says that it's not
gonna be till the first six months that
probably means we're not gonna see a
whole lot of x-men stuff happening
during avengers endgame
so just couch your expectations in terms
of post-credit scenes think more along
the lines of future sequels like Black
Panther sequels the Eternals movie other
things that they've started to talk
about and already confirm for phase four
pretty easy assumption to make that
there will be some plot twist during
avengers endgame that will allow for the
explanation for how x-men can exist
within the MCU so we'll talk about that
when we start getting more trailers
there was a new promo art for Avengers
and games that just posted Iron Man in
his gold comic book looking armor it's
really just an iteration of his infinity
war armor with the gold arms made to
look more like his classic comic book
armor even though this looks kind of
weird
it is technically official promo art
this is gonna be going on a lot of
merchandising stuff that they'll be
promoting the film with so Hulk
wearing that special armor that we saw
him in and the other promo art just
seeming to corroborate that'll actually
be wearing a special suit that will
expand when he Hulk's out I seen a lot
of people speculating about this piece
of Iron Man art thinking that he's
wearing a different suit of armor just
because the neckline in the shoulders
look a little bit different they're
colored differently from his infinity
war armor and from this gold armor so
yes it is totally possible that Iron Man
wears multiple different suits there was
a list of Lego toys that just posted for
the sets that they're going to be making
for the movie and one of them just
happened to be Iron Man's armory so a
lot of people are just expecting this
concept art to be a real thing during
endgame because we didn't see anything
like this during infinity war remember
when they released the very first teaser
for infinity war and it was them behind
the scenes and there was a bunch of
concept art we saw thorn rocket fighting
the Midgard serpent wielding yar bjorn
his axe from the comics so obviously
there were a lot of changes between the
concept phase before they actually got
to the final cut of the film but even
though some of the translations on these
sort of break the sentences so they
don't quite make sense you can kind of
pick out what they're trying to imply
here
Captain America attack of the outrider
that's just more out writers like the
dogs with the forearms that they fought
during infinity war from the comics war
machine crusher makes it sound more like
his armor has some badass function
during
game that we haven't seen yet or it
could be him being crushed by some large
contraption because it's meant to be a
giant Lego set not just a single figure
but then obviously Iron Man armor room
that's pretty self-explanatory it's been
a while since we've seen one of Iron
Man's armor ease so you have to imagine
in the time jump between when now an end
game happens in the timeline he's
probably made a couple more suits right
now Avengers super Quinn jet just sounds
like it's much more heavily armored
version of a regular Quinn jet we do
know that because Hulk went to Sekar in
a regular Quinn jet
they're already capable of flying in
space the last one which is supposed to
be the biggest Lego set sounds like it's
their big final battle against Thanos
whatever that's going to look like
that's usually when they embellish a
little bit like I would just assume that
most of the characters that show up
during this show up during that scene
during the movie but the way that they
present it when you see the toy might
not be exactly the way the scene goes
down in the movie I know there's a bunch
of Spider Man far from home toys on here
too molten man hydro-man Stark's plane
drone attack I'll talk about that when I
do another Spider Man far from home
video there was just a lot of news that
dropped this morning this is a much
better picture of Hawkeye's Ronin
costume from the front because we only
see it from the back in the trailer so a
lot of this stuff mostly just
corroborates earlier concept art that
we've seen but remember if you saw any
of the deleted scene videos that I did
for infinity war there is a lot of
different types of concept art that they
did that did not actually make the final
cut of the film like Kevin Feige says
they've been working on Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame for
the last five years so don't be
surprised if some of the stuff you see
in the concept art and the promos only
winds up making it on screen for a
couple seconds like characters will get
multiple costumes we've already seen
Captain America go through two separate
costume changes in the recent Avengers
endgame trailer in the Infinity war suit
that he's been ripped up the scale armor
underneath that and in the Winter
Soldier stealth suit remember a lot of
that footage is probably just from the
first 20 minutes of the movie so as to
avoid a lot of big spoilers so that's
only the beginning of Avengers costume
changes but also really special news
speaking of the first 20 minutes of the
movie the Russo brothers and Marvel are
going to be doing an early fan screening
of Avengers end game way before anybody
else gets to see it at st. Andrews
University probably sometime in early
April because the movies coming
at the end of April but if you remember
they did the same thing for infinity war
they only screened about the first 20
minutes of the film it wasn't that
spoilery and it was mostly to head off
certain spoilers at the past so if you
do live around that area there's a
pretty good chance you see a chunk of
the film before anyone else whatever
ends up happening I'll totally do a
breakdown video of it but obviously
there's gonna be a lot more trailers
before then we have all the Captain
Marvel stuff there's a lot of stuff to
talk about leave all your requests in
the comments below they'll probably be
another Captain Marvel video soon
because they confirm some big details
about the characters especially Jude
Law's mystery character quote-unquote we
finally found out for real who he is
although I think that Marvel's still
kind of being misleading so I'll talk
about that during my next Captain Marvel
video there is a new round of that I max
to get giveaway to because it's the
holidays all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
Avengers endgame moments so far on the
video while you wait for everything
click here to rewatch the full Avengers
endgame trailer and click here for all
my new once upon a Deadpool post-credit
scenes thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you